[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Gauthier
quand on parle de vous on dit souvent
vous êtes une chasseuse de génocidaire
rwandais est-ce que vous acceptez cette
expression
écoutez je n'ai rien demandé je crois ce
sont les journalistes vous autres qui
avaient
vraiment inventé cette expression qu'il
avait officialisé moi je n'ai pas je ne
suis pas lever matin on vous assimile on
va vous compare souvent à Serge et
clarsfeld parce que avec votre mari vous
essayez de retrouver des gens qui ont
participé à ce sujet aussi de Rwanda
c'est une comparaison qui vous convient
c'est pas que ça nous convient pas
encore une fois c'est un terme
institutionnalisé par les journalistes
mais il se trouve que c'était un
raccourci mais qui permet quand même de
faire comprendre au public le travail
qu'on fait quand on poursuit des nazis
ou quand on poursuit des génocidaires
rwandais pour moi il y a pas de
différence bien sûr
vous avez rencontré votre mari au Rwanda
Alain Gauthier qui est français lui qui
était oui il est il est coopérant il a
il a connu le Rwanda en qualité de
coopérant dans quelles circonstances
vous avez rencontré alors écoutez il a
enseigné Abou Taret à côté de boutarik
du mois
mais en tout cas il était prof et il
enseignait dans un établissement il y
avait un de mes cousin Joseph et il y
avait aussi ma soeur donc en fait il
était plutôt pote avec mes
ma famille voilà que moi-même
le génocide du Rwanda c'est plus de 800
000 morts en trois mois en 1994 d'avril
à juillet 1994 et vous avez perdu une
grande partie de votre famille
dans cette dans ce génocide
mais je crois que quand on est tout
petit du Rwanda je crois qu'on a
énormément perdu la famille de ma mère
il y a pas de survivant à ce jour
je sais pas si je les ai comptés mais
50-80 ans vous savez aujourd'hui
on ne compte que des survivants
parce que les morts il y en a eu
tellement dans nos familles il y en a eu
tellement moi j'étais tellement dans 73
et il se trouve qu'il y en a qui sont
nés après mon départ puisque j'étais
réfugiée politique je ne pouvais plus
rentrer et voilà donc on arrive même pas
à compter les morts tellement tellement
il y en a Roberto de la famille de ma
mère c'était dans la région de boutarré
et des oncles des tentes des cousins des
petits cousins aujourd'hui il y a
personne que vous n'avez jamais jamais
jamais jamais retrouvé
est-ce que
avec votre mari vous avez commencé à
vous mettre en quête justement des
génocidaires à essayer de faire la
lumière sur ces événements horribles
tout à fait exceptionnels assez
tardivement longtemps après finalement
si je peux me permettre je crois que
c'est au tournant des années 2000 que
vous avez commencé à consacrer beaucoup
de temps à ça mais c'est à dire que l'on
collectif des parties civils a été créé
en 2001 c'est l'association à
l'association que vous avez créé voilà
c'est le collectif des participes pour
le Rwanda donc on a créé cette
association pour se donner un cadre de
travail un cadre pour pouvoir avancer
pour pouvoir
se doter d'un outil en quelque sorte
mais dès notre retour en 96 là où on
comptait justement on essayait de
retrouver des survivants de
la famille et des amis d'ailleurs aussi
c'est là où on a commencé à récolter des
témoignages
on est tombé sur quelques rescapés de la
famille quelqu'un naufragé et qui ont
commencé à nous raconter leur récit
évidemment effrayant comment on peut
le penser et c'est en ce moment-là on a
commencé à vraiment à l'écrire on a
écrit on a écrit
97 en retourne on continue ce travail
d'écrire vous avez recueilli des
témoignages des témoignages j'ai on
avait des cahiers on recueillait des
témoignages
97 la matière commençait déjà à être
assez conséquente on a continué 97 98 et
c'est réellement autour de 2000 et 2001
il y a eu le fameux procès de Bruxelles
contre les quatre de boutarrés beaucoup
en ont entendu parler
à Bruxelles en Belgique et se trouve que
je suis très liée à cette communauté
rwandaise de Belgique c'est là où j'ai
fait une partie de mes études et c'est
là où résidait mon frère un autre
réfugié des années 60 qui m'a accueilli
après 73 et il se trouve que dès 94 eux
ils se sont constitués en collectif et
on acheminait un peu avec eux jusqu'au
procès de 2001 et ça nous a donné
vraiment des ailes de rodace pour
pouvoir se dire tiens et si on créait le
collectif pour aussi essayer de faire
quelque chose en France alors revenons
aux origines de sujets nocides donc ce
génocide c'est en 1994 qu'il est commis
c'est la majorité autour du pays qui
s'en prend donc à la minorité tutsi dont
vous faites partie
ces deux ethnies sont des ethnies
cousines finalement qui sont des ethnies
Bantous il y en a une les Tutsis qui
viennent plutôt de la vallée du Nil les
Hutu venant plutôt du Sud
et
il y a des causes qui sont alors
certains les expliquent par la
colonisation certains disent que les
Tutsis auraient été avantagés par les
colons le Rwanda c'est une colonie qui a
d'abord été une colonie allemande avant
d'être une colonie belge et donc à ce
titre là parce qu'ils auraient toujours
été
favorisés par les colons et bien les
Hutus avaient un désir de revanche
qu'est-ce que vous dites de cette
version des faits
alors je peux pas faire l'histoire du
Rwanda un petit peu d'autre mais ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que les Hutus et
les Tutsis ont toujours vécu en harmonie
on vit sur la même Coline
on a des mariages mixte on se connaît on
échange des vaches on échange de on se
marie entre nous aussi
il faut dire que c'est antagonisme entre
houtou et outils c'est sûr que l'origine
vient de la colonisation confirmer ça
il est pas resté longtemps avec elle
Allemagne a perdu ses colonies après la
Première Guerre mondiale où en fait le
Rwanda et le Burundi d'ailleurs sont
revenus à la Belgique c'est ça sous
tutelle belge
où le roi Léopold possédait le grand
Congo à côté
il se trouve aussi quand même 2900 on a
des missionnaires on a des Pères Blancs
qui arriveront donc ils vont trouver une
qui est très organisé et si bien que ils
se sont dit on va s'appuyer sur cette
société là et sur ce qui c'est qui l'a
ouvert dans cette saison les
organisateurs de cette société ils se
trouvent que Rwanda c'était un royaume
c'était toujours autour du roi et à ce
titre
la Belgique qui a repris après
l'Allemagne et les
missionnaires qui sont arrivés en même
temps ce sont tous appuyés sur la
société existante c'est-à-dire au Royal
l'organisation royale existante et le
roi était tout petit le roi était tout
petit le roi était tout petit mais il
pouvait y avoir aussi des chefs des
sous-chefs qui étaient où à l'époque
mais je pense que ça a été exacerbé par
le Colomb belge qui a vraiment créé
cette antagonisme entre les outre et des
Tutsis en favorisant des outils leur
donnant enfin un exacerbant c'est
privilège là et si bien que dès 1931
d'ailleurs cette société a été
complètement figée puisque il a été créé
des cartes d'identité ou tout et tout
dit et je pense que l'origine c'est
vraiment 1931 on a figé cette société là
c'est divisé en route tout outils alors
que nous étions des classes sociales
donc vous confirmez un peu ce que je
disais et alors il faut le dire en 1994
donc le Président Juvénal à biarrimana
revient d'un sommet international lui il
est toutous et son avion est descendu
par
des
tirs depuis Kigali et on ne sait trop
d'ailleurs si ce tirs sont diligentés
par les Hutus afin justement de
justifier ce génocide ou si il est il a
d'autres causes ce qui est sûr c'est que
cette événement est un événement qui va
ravagé les relations internationales
parce que la France elle-même sera mise
en cause dans cette histoire certains
estiment que la France d'une certaine
façon a été à soutenu les Hutus dans
cette dans ce génocide qu'est-ce que
vous dites de ça
là il faut faire une petite explication
revenir en arrière et du faux comprendre
ce qui s'est passé la montée de la
violence au Rwanda ne date pas de 94 il
y a eu des exactions avant sa date de
1959 ou justement pour entre guillemets
punir les Tutsi on les a chassés et du
pouvoir et on les a chassés aussi du
pays tout le monde n'était pas au
pouvoir il y avait des soucis sans
pouvoir c'était juste des outils et des
citoyens ordinaires donc dès 1959
justement le Coran qui a voulu favoriser
la majorité où tout mais pourquoi ça
s'est passé c'est à dire que dans les
années 50 vous connaissez vous savez que
le
c'était les pays africains ont demandé
leur indépendance et Rwanda en faisait
partie
roi de Mohamed a demandé aussi
l'indépendance du roi et ça n'a pas du
tout plus au côlon et voilà c'est bien
que en ce moment-là il a commencé à se
rebeller et à favoriser les Hutus en
disant d'ailleurs vous êtes beaucoup
plus nombreux voilà
c'est comme ça que ça doit être donc
l'auberge a changé de demain après avoir
favorisé les outils il a favoriser
quand même cette violence son nom contre
les tuts contre les chassant du pays les
tuans les en faisant des des de la
population de la seconde zone le citoyen
de second zone en localifiant de tous
les noms un peu de
tous les insectes que vous pouvez
imaginer
peu avant
l'indépendance en 54 j'étais quand même
jeune en 509 mais j'ai quand même vu je
me suis vu chasser de ma maison j'ai des
souvenirs plus ou moins précis pas
complètement mais la violence vous savez
quand
vous commencez bien avant un génocide ne
peut pas avoir lieu sans idéologie donc
cette idéologie Dora haine est montée de
59 mais en puissance tout doucement tout
doucement quand on a commencé justement
à dire que le tout petit
il est mauvais en affaire il est
malhonnête c'est un peu les mêmes
clichés ce qu'on dit sur les Juifs donc
du coup
cette idéologie là était très très bien
ancrée surtout dans la classe
intellectuelle du pays et évidemment là
je on va passer plusieurs détails on va
arriver en 94 où il y a eu cette
solution finale la seule manière pour le
Rwanda disait ceux qui ont commis le
génocide la seule façon de qui est la
paix c'est la solution finale c'est de
tuer les outils jusqu'au dernier
jusqu'au dernier
de la France vous en avez un peu parlé
on peut revenir sur les accords de
coopération de 75 jusqu'à là il n'y
avait pas énormément d'attaches de la
France au Rwanda mais dès 90 avec
l'amitié du président Mitterrand du
président
il y a eu quand même une aide nette
militaire une aide diplomatique
des moyens
en armes il y a eu énormément de moyens
qui ont été donnés à l'État doit bien
est-ce que la France le gouvernement
français de l'époque le président
s'était François Mitterrand le Premier
ministre était Édouard Balladur est-ce
que à votre avis ils se sont rendus
comme le dit un journaliste qui
s'appelle Patrick de Saint-Exupéry comme
le dit Bernard Kouchner qui parle de
d'erreurs criminelle est-ce que il y a
une certaine passivité au sommet de
l'État français face à ce génocide
moi j'irai même au-delà nous dans la
nous les associatifs nous les gens
ordinaires les associations on n'a pas
arrêté de dénoncer de dénoncer de
dénoncer mais on n'a pas été du tout
entendu je remercie Patrick
Saint-Exupéry qui qui a alerté très tôt
dès 98 à travers une série d'articles
publiés
aussi qui n'a pas non plus
disons
qui ne sait pas tue
en Somalie c'est ça je pense que
là ils sont complètement validés par
rapport de Monsieur Duclair qui est
sorti l'année dernière le rapport du
clair il conclut comment il conclut par
la faillite de l'État la faillite de
l'armée des responsabilités lourdes et
accablantes alors quand vous entendez
des conclusions comme ça après un
rapport de 12
évidemment il y a tout il y a tout
dedans elle a faillite de cet état moi
je vous conseille de le lire au moins le
chapitre 7 la troisième Gauthier votre
action
elle a abouti
à ce que des criminels
soit passible de la justice il y a eu
des procès donc vous ce que vous avez
poursuivi vous les poursuivez en France
ce sont des Rwandais qui se sont
réfugiés en France après le génocide
pour fuir leur responsabilité
philajustice puis la justice combien de
personnes à ce jour
nous sommes en 2022
et bien ont pu être poursuivi grâce à
votre action malheureusement très peu il
y a eu pour l'instant on a eu cinq
procès trois ont été définitivement
condamnés
aux assises un ancien militaire deux
anciens maires 25 ans pour le militaire
la perpétuité pour les deux mers et
ensuite mère et exmère et là
il y a eu un musicien qui a été condamné
à 14
il a fait appel et là un préfet a été
condamné à 20 ans mais il a fait appel
aussi oui récemment au printemps il faut
dire que les génocidaires qui sont
poursuivi en justice certains quand ils
sont retrouvés en France sont jugés en
France la plupart sont jugés en France
pourquoi c'est selon la loi de
compétences universelle parce qu'ils
sont sûrs le sol français il faut ils
ont commis les crimes à l'étranger sur
des étrangers
et il réside sur le sol français je
crois que j'ai oublié un élément mais
peu importe mais pourquoi aussi ils sont
jugés ici donc selon cette loi là mais
parce que la France n'extrade pas ça
aussi il faut le dire la France pas
l'extrape pas refuse de renvoyer enfin
de livrer aux autorités rwandaises
d'aujourd'hui
des génocidaires parce qu'il faut le
savoir au Rwanda il y a un tribunal
pénal international
éviter toute forme de vengeance et vous
continuez là votre mission j'ai envie de
dire
vous savez il y a plus de 30 dossiers
sur les bureaux des juges si à Paris
donc là on a un procès au mois de mai
prochain contre un ancien gendarme et à
la fin de l'année un procès contre un
médecin Gauthier qu'est-ce que vous
pensez du Rwanda aujourd'hui 30 ans
après il est dirigé par un homme qui est
réputé pour être assez autoritaire qui
s'appelle Paul Kagame
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de votre pays
qui s'est redressé de façon assez
impressionnante quand même parce qu'il
est montré en exemple aujourd'hui
beaucoup disent le Rwanda c'est pardon
ça paraît complètement aberrant 30 ans
après un génocide c'est la Suisse de
l'Afrique qu'est-ce que vous pensez je
pense que réellement au moins de sévère
avec Paul Kagame sévère avec Rwanda le
monde n'est pas juste est-ce que c'est
parce que ils nous ont abandonné au
moment de 94
qui sont obligés de dire des choses le
Rwanda a fait des efforts à tout point
de vue
le monde de la justice ils ont jugé ils
ont acquitté aussi d'ailleurs c'est la
justice c'est aussi ça c'est la kit main
et c'est condamné et à quitté il y a eu
des efforts énormes ils ont reconstruire
le pays
à tout point de vue c'est plutôt
flatteur de dire que vous êtes la Suisse
africaine non mais bien sûr mais c'est
toujours il y a toujours un petit côté
oui mais c'est la Petite Suisse
d'Afrique mais en fait c'est parce que
il y a un dictateur sur
autoritaire mais bon je sais pas si vous
êtes d'ailleurs très proche de lui c'est
vrai ou pas
je connais mon président mais comme vous
vous connaissez notre président ici mais
je connais pas en tant que
je suis pas intime de mon mais je
reconnais je reconnais donc vous êtes
assez fier de la façon dont ce pays
c'est redressé
je suis fière de ce que mon pays a fait
de cette bonne gouvernance qui a permis
que les Rwandais puisse revivre ensemble
cohabiter ensemble
ou tout et tout si revivent ensemble
bien sûr et de vivre sur la même colline
et ça reste depuis la nuit des temps on
vit ensemble
mon voisin peut être tout type peut être
autour voilà
j'y vais souvent nous irons souvent pour
les besoins de la justice justement pour
les besoins des enquêtes etc alors voilà
Kigali qui est la capitale avec ses
gratte-ciel c'est vraiment un pays qui
aujourd'hui a une croissance
exceptionnelle un des pays les plus
dynamiques d'Afrique aujourd'hui bon je
pense que beaucoup de pays après une
guerre je crois que ça s'est vu aussi
après la deuxième guerre il me semble
que aussi elle repart reconstruit j'ai
l'impression que les pays comme quel que
soit l'endroit une fois qu'elle a paix
est revenue forcément on se reconstruit
sauf si on n'a pas de leadership donc il
faut dire d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de dire
tout à l'heure qui est tout de suite lui
il faut le dire aussi maintenant oui
mais
c'est pas parce qu'il est tout petit ou
qui est
le premier
il va comme ça on est tous des
ronds évidemment des connoté parce que
c'est un ancien chef de guerre c'est
c'est lui qui a arrêté le génocide et ça
on en entend pas beaucoup parler
c'est le FPR
existait déjà en 1994 bien sûr c'est eux
qui ont combattu pour la libération du
Rwanda après le génocide
oui c'est grâce à eux qu'on a pu revivre
je pense
[Musique]
envie de choisir une culture plutôt que
l'autre si je vous dis
ça vous dit quoi
c'est notre enfant c'est votre genre
oui c'est un artiste donc musicien
écrivain aussi il a écrit un livre qui a
eu le prix Goncourt des lycéens qui
s'appelle petit pays il travaille avec
vous dans le cadre de l'association non
il consacre du temps aussi à ça
l'association oui il est secrétaire du
collectif des parties civils oui je suis
des dossiers oui bien sûr j'ai lu
quelque part
d'afrosa Gauthier que en fait chez vous
il y avait ni
ni esprit de vengeance
mais un souci de justice dans votre
action
vous savez si vous commencez à vous
venger ou si vous commencez à ça c'est
pas la justice en fait la justice c'est
lutter contre l'oubli contre l'impunité
mais c'est un travail sérieux c'était un
travail du roi il faut il faut la preuve
la justice c'est toujours la preuve sans
la preuve personne ne peut être condamné
votre action ah oui c'est la justice et
c'est la lutte contre l'intimité parce
que quand on est tout petit et qu'on a
vécu au Rwanda pendant toutes ces années
là et que on n'a jamais eu de justice
ça vous marque toute une vie et vous il
n'y a pas de haine chez vous
j'ai pas le temps en fait j'ai pas le
temps la haine c'est quelqu'un chose qui
peut vous ravager et qui peut vous faire
commettre des bêtises et qui peut aussi
vous inhiber et vous prendre toute votre
énergie alors je n'en ai pas pour ça je
vais la consacrer à la justice
merci d'afrrosa Gauthier merci beaucoup